هذا شيء يسمى G con ، لقد قمت بالاستحمام بوقت
وقد تم ممارسته هنا
لأكثر من 300 عام
، حيث يتم نقعه في الماء الكبريتي الحارق لمدة ثلاث دقائق
onsen no kami-sama neat
glass وهذا نوعًا ما يبدأ بالصلاة
[تصفيق]
أعني أنك تقوم بالصلاة من قبل  أنت على
وشك أن تفعل شيئًا ما يجعلني أشعر
بالتوتر قليلاً الآن ، أرسل لي حسنًا ، دعنا
نحصل عليهم عندما أقف على القوارب ، فماذا
عنك فقط أن تختار مع هذا الجانب قطع
هذا الماء ما يقرب من مائة
وخمسة عشر درجة في أمريكا إنه غير
قانوني  قم بتشغيل الماء بعد 104 درجة حتى في
حوض الاستحمام الساخن قبل أن ندخل في الحمام ،
نقوم بطقوس تسمى أنت يا أمي
والتي تهدف إلى المساعدة في تبريد الأشياء قليلاً
في الماء لمدة
ثلاث دقائق بينما يعد رئيس الحمام
العد التنازلي لشيء ما ، ثم
سنقول أوه هذا ليس فيديو
ما هو معنى ذلك عندما نقول
إنها ستعرف أبينا وأعتقد
أنها تريد التأكد  نحن ما زلنا على قيد الحياة
[م  usic]
مرحبًا بالربو المنتصب ، لقد رأيت هذا الرجل الذي
يتخيل موقفًا كرتونيًا ،
وهو يبني ارتفاعًا ذاتيًا يبدو
كرتونيًا ، هل تريد أن تصاب بالذعر
[موسيقى]
سأذهب إلى مكان مختلف داخل
رأسي حار مثل هذا أتخيل
الثلج  والجليد هذا شيء جيد لقد
قابلت كل أطفالي ،
نعم لقد صنعناه